[Music]
here we are in the whole Valley rain
forest
this is a cathedral lie Cathedral in
this forest is the quietest place in the
entire United States and it's only one
square inch in size my mission is to
keep it that way
I'm Gordon Hempton I'm a sound tracker I
travel the globe in search of vanishing
sounds including the most endangered of
all which is simply silence noise
pollution is nearly enix capable the
whole valley is the quietest least noise
polluted place and the entire lower 48 I
don't know if I can save silence but I
know that I can try so it was 12 years
ago
2005 Earth Day that I hiked up the whole
River Valley
it took three miles just to escape the
numbers of the parking lot that's when I
was looking in every direction for which
way I should go
I saw the elk trail love to follow their
advice because they loved quiet just
like I do
and they led me right to the spot it's
just through that tree I defend this one
square inch of silence by doing both
quiet and noise monitoring when a noise
intrusion occurs I locate the noise
maker send them a letter and ask for
compliance this matter is urgent within
10 years it's likely that there will be
no quiet places left unless we take
action when I first started I did not
think silence would go extinct in my
lifetime and if that happens the quiet
will disappear and the wildlife will be
devastated
the one square inch of silence
foundation is pressing our politicians
to pass a single piece of legislation
that will designate Olympic National
Park as the world's first quiet park
off-limits
to aircraft all things are possible the
earth is here and it's beautiful and for
me it all starts here in the whole
valley